joining us now pollster Lee Carter and
New York Post reporter John LaVine thank
you both for being here Joe stands at a
Podium uh Lee and says you're better off
financially that's a fact that's a fact
I'm going to State it as a fact yet the
numbers that morning Joe is so scared of
show that on immigration on the economy
on inflation people see it upside down
they know who's running this economy
into the ground how bad are those
numbers they're horrible I mean there is
just nothing that you can look at it
that takes anything good about where Joe
Biden stands on the economy on inflation
on immigration on all the issues that
matter most his approval rating is at
the floor most people say Republicans
can do way better than he can and yet
his response is all that polling stuff
says that everybody's never felt better
it is the absolute opposite of what he
should be doing I mean nothing kills
trust faster than a contradiction if you
tell somebody who feels really bad and
most people do feel really bad about
their grocery bills and their their
energy bills and everything else and you
tell them that it's never been better
they're just going to reject you and
that's what we're seeing across the
board does this uh have you seen these
numbers work their way into National and
state-based presidential polls we've
seen Donald Trump move into a lead in
many of those they're trying to say
they're outliers uh lee but is it making
its way into the polling because there
are some that say well people don't like
Donald Trump so they're not going to
move in his Direction but it seems it is
moving in that
direction it does seem it's moving in
that direction and the seven states that
matter the most when you look at Donald
Trump actually has an advantage and when
you look at some of the key demographics
that were the ones that carried Joe
Biden into office in 2020 he's actually
losing ground by about 10 points he's
lost a ground with African-Americans
he's lost ground with women Suburban
women Hispanics all across the board
those those those voters that really
carried him into the presidency are now
turning away from him and it is a big
big problem he seems very out of touch
you should take a a a page out of the
Playbook I feel your pain would be
something that would go a long way but
in instead he says look biomics things
have never been better and everybody
knows better people aren't stupid but
he's not smart enough to change his tune
I mean old dog do tricks that's the
situation we're in right now John let me
move to that second part of the story
too because it seems they're just
doubling down on the on the protection
racket here I mean okay we've got a
special counsel that oversees
whistleblowers we've had a whistleblower
problem here in the Biden Administration
so let's and we we're not saying this is
some loose Association we know through
emails from the laptop that Hunter Biden
know the guy coming in to run the
special council is this just cover for
them it is a real case of who will
monitor the monitors this is a very
Clubby Democratic Law Firm it has only
about 150 attorneys Hunter Biden and the
individual who was just nominated to
this post were both senior employees at
this firm and I think it shows a certain
arrogance by the White House that they
feel they can just do this and the
American people won't care or won't
notice and you know to to the point your
guest made earlier there are bigger
immediate problems in this country for
ordinary people but this is just a drop
in the bucket if you look at the larger
Hunter Biden Scandal president uh when
he was Vice President Joe Biden was
meeting with business partners in the
White House Joe Biden is putting Hunter
the people that are buying Hunter
Biden's art into government commissions
I mean the recklessness and the
arrogance and they think the American
people are stupid and they think the
American people don't care and
ultimately it is going to be something
that has to get adjudicated by the
American people in the 2024 election
they're going to be the half to ones
that say look is this something we care
about or not is this a factor in our
vote and are we going to hold Joe Biden
accountable or not and they're certainly
I guess they're counting on it's just
another drip in the Washington Intrigue
we're going to pick our partisan sides
most of the media will take our defense
um and so you can count on that I I
don't want to speculate here but how
problematic is the investigations in the
house sort of pausing if we want to get
to the bottom of Hunter and Joe well
look you know we these investigations
are operating on a timetable you know
Democrats are trying to run out the
clock in the hope that they take back
the house in 2024 and then they shut
down the probe so when the house is in
chaos we're not doing the probe and
we're we're we're wasting days every
single day is critical it takes such a
long time to get these bank records the
process of subpoenaing individuals is
not like you just send out a subpoena
you've got to send letters there's
negotiation with lawyers every single
day that we lose picking a new speaker
or in house chaos sets us back in every
direction on this probe no question
about it Lee real quick uh 20 seconds
does do developments like this register
with voters or are bigger issues just
overwhelming at all
well I think it does register because
More than 70% of Americans and that's
across the aisle say that the system is
rigged to favor the elite and ruling
class and that doesn't mean Donald Trump
they think that Donald Trump 60% of
Americans say is the only one that they
can fight back and so most people are
seeing uh through this and it's a big
issue and I think these kinds of
appointments these kinds of issues
actually make it worse not better there
you go Le and John thank you both for
being here hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else